approximately how long does it take to
travel to mars
asking for a friend asking for a friend
as we all do
uh about three years for a round trip
okay and that's not that it actually why
the round trip is that well
you're just asking about the one trip
uh it's okay cool so for just like
literally flying to mars and around it
takes three years there's some
interstitial time there because you
really can only go between earth and
mars at certain points in their orbits
where it's favorable to make that
journey and so part of that three years
is you take the journey to mars a few
months six to nine months you're there
for a period of time until the orbits
find a favorable alignment again and
then you come back another six to nine
months so one way travel six to nine
months they hang out there on vacation
then come back forced vacation
well me who loves working all the time
all vacation is forced vacation uh all
right
uh so okay so that gives us a sense of
duration and we can maybe also talk
about longer and longer and longer
duration
uh as well
what are the hardest aspects of
this of living in space for
many days for let's say 100 days 200
days maybe there's a threshold when it
gets really tough what are what are some
stupid little things or big things that
are very difficult for human beings to
go through so one big thing and one
little thing there's two classic
problems that we're trying to solve in
the space industry one is radiation
it's not as much of a problem for us
right now on the international space
station because we're still protected by
part of earth's magnetosphere but as
soon as you get farther out into space
and you don't have that protection once
you leave the van allen
belt area of the earth and the you know
cocoon around the earth
we have really serious concerns about
radiation the effect on human health
long term that's the big one
the small one and i say it's small
because it seems mundane but it actually
is really big in its own way is mental
health and how to keep people happy and
balanced and you were alluding to some
of the psychological challenges of
having humans together on missions and
especially as we try to scale the number
of humans in orbit or in space
so that's another big challenge is how
to keep people happy and balanced and
cooperating
that's not an issue on earth at all at
all
okay so
we'll talk about each of those in a bit
more detail but
let me continue on the chain of dumb
questions what about food what's a good
food source for food in space
and what are some sort of standard go-to
meals menus right now your go-to menu is
going to be mostly freeze-dried every so
often nasa will arrange for a fun stunt
or fresh food to get up to station so
they did bake double tree cookies with
hilton a couple years ago as i recall i
think sometime before the pandemic
but there's work actually in our lab at
mit maggie koblenz one of my staff
researchers is looking at the future of
fermentation everybody loves beer right
beer and wine and kimchi and miso these
foods that have just been you know
really important to human cultures for
eons because we love the umami and the
better flavor in them but it turns out
they also have a good shelf life if done
properly and they also have an
additional health benefit for the
microbiome for probiotics and prebiotics
so we're trying to work with nasa and
convince them to be more open-minded to
fermented food for long-duration deep
space missions that we think is one of
the future elements in addition to
institute growing your own food no okay
this is this is essential for the space
party is the yes the space beer yes it's
the fermented product yes
okay cool in terms of water what's a
good source of drinkable water like
where do you get water do you have to
always bring it on board with you and is
there a compressed efficient way of
storing it so to steal a line from
charlie bolden who's the former
administrator of nasa uh this morning's
fresh water is yesterday's coffee
so if you think about what that means
you drank the coffee yesterday right as
it turned out it goes fully through the
body through the body as the recycling
system and then you drink what you peed
out as um
you know clarified uh refined fresh
water the next day that is one source of
water another source of water in the
near neighborhood of our solar system
would be on the moon so water ice
deposits there's also water on mars this
is one of the big things that's bringing
people to want to develop infrastructure
on the moon is once you've gotten out of
the gravity well of earth if you can
find water on the moon and refine it you
can either make it into propellant or
drinkable water for humans
and so that's really valuable as a
potential gateway out into the rest of
the solar system to be able to get
propellant without always having to ship
it up from earth
you